hi I love you thank you you seem very nice
so we're like in the future no wait we're not in
the future I was supposed to be back
in the present but I'm still in the
past and there's not supposed to be
two of me hey do the thing again fine
oh yeah
I went back in time to save my mom
but I completely destroyed history
I'm gonna change the past you changed the future I
I created a world with no
many humans want some help
I'm Batman
this world must die what's the light
Batman what do we do we try not to die
what did you do no nobody dies
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Flash trailer video there's a whole bunch
of new footage in an international version of the
trailer like it's a completely different trailer
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll do a giveaway for movie tickets when
we get a little bit closer to the movie actually
coming out and big reminder too there's a big
Snyder con that's happening right now he might
release some new deleted scenes or some new
footage so if anything cool winds up coming
from that of course I'll do videos for it as well
the big news too is that Henry cavill's Superman
actually is featured in the movie we thought that
he'd been taken out because he did film new scenes
as Superman but it was meant to set up this big
crisis on infinite Earth as they were building
to like a previous 10-year Plan before they hired
James Gunn and he rebooted DC movies into the DCU
so a lot of the Cameo scenes from characters
like Henry Cavill Superman in particular in a
lot of these different films that are coming out
this year had to be changed because they didn't
want to set up things that they would never
wind up paying off but reportedly after that
they still feature Henry Cavill Superman in the
movie but it's footage from the justice League
Snyder cut previously we just thought that they
completely cut him out of the movie there's also
supposed to be some Wonder Woman in the movie
as well too I'll explain because Ben Affleck
made it sound like she's actually still in the
movie like they didn't completely cut her scene
out the director Andy muschietti also said that
they would probably do a flash sequel movie like
The Flash 2 if this movie does well enough and
the way everyone who's seen it is reacting to it
they're talking about it like it's going to cure
cancer on planet Earth like that's how good it's
supposed to be and they'll just find some way of
saying how this ties into James Gunn's rebooted
DCU the funny thing about all these actors in
DC movies being recast is that the movies are
successful enough like if they make enough money
the ones that are still coming out this year the
actors will come back that's why we probably
won't see a ton of the Shazam characters or
like The Rock's Black Adam character coming back
just because those movies were not viewed as being
financially successful Blue Beetle is like the
next chance of a character coming back the way
James Gunn talks about it he does make it sound
like Blue Beetle will be part of his new Gods and
Monsters DC chapter one but the new trailer starts
with him in Central City in the new Flash suit
maybe it's one of the first times that he's
wearing it the whole idea is that Ben Affleck's
Batman is the one who creates the flash ring from
the comics which contains the flash like the suit
comes out of the ring just like the comics they
did a version of that on The Flash TV show several
seasons ago so up to this point he just continued
to use his suit inside the flash ring this scene
begins with him bursting out of the diner and
it's meant to be a reference to the Justice
League Snyder cutscene of him doing something
similar like he was inside a business and saves
Iris West during a car crash that she was having
and you see how the speed force Works around
him it was meant to be kind of a tutorial in how
the flash looks in the Justice League Snyder cut
oh
Andy muschetti the director of this movie hasn't
changed too much about the way the flash moves
the way his powers work they tuned up the
visualization just a little bit and I know
there's some questions about why the color of
his speed Force lightning changes I'll explain
that when we get to that part of the trailer too
for the most part they're trying to keep as much
continuity between the Justice League Snyder cut
in this movie this time at the beginning of the
trailer the reason why he's in the coffee shop
wearing the business suit is because he's been
working at the Central City Police Department as
a forensic investigator just like he was in the
comics and just like he is in The Flash TV show
with the Grant Gustin version within the movies he
got the job right at the end of the Justice League
Snyder cut like he was bragging to his father look
I applied for a job at the Central City police
department and it was meant to be them starting
to do the comic book origin of the character
the other joke here too is that he changes into
his flash suit using the flash ring inside the
bathroom the coffee shop just to hide a secret
identity which is a reference to the classic
Superman Trope of changing and phone boosts in
the comics the cartoons the Christopher Reeve
version of Superman they had a couple of jokes
about that when they got to the Brandon Routh
Superman Returns movie 2 2 he was supposed to
be the same version of Superman as the Christopher
Reeve version just a little bit older another fun
connection to crisis on infinite Earth in the DC
TV shows is that when he came back during that on
Earth 96 he was meant to be the same version as
his version from Superman Returns the reason why
it was Earth 96 though is because during crisis on
infinite Earth they were saying that the events of
the Kingdom Come storyline happened on his Earth
to his character and it was published in 1996.
the joke that they begin the trailer on though
is because this is happening after the events
of the Justice League Snyder cut he's been taking
down other flash Rogues and criminals in Central
City for a little while on top of that he started
to become a celebrity in the news like the dude
on the street pulls out his cell phone starts
taking clips of him like that's been happening
for a while now but the funny thing is is that
during crisis on infinite Earths they actually
gave him the flash name I don't know if that's
gonna stick or if Iris West during the movie is
going to give him the flash name because that's
the way they did on the TV show Iris West is the
person who called him the flash the Joker in
crisis on infinite Earths is that even during
the Justice League Snyder cut like even up to
that point all of Ezra Miller's time is The
Flash nobody had ever called him the Flash in any
of the movies I'm also The Flash he also the what
The Flash The Flash it's complicated so when Grant
Gustin had that moment telling him I'm the flash
he was hearing it for the first time like the
flash wow that actually sounds like a pretty cool
name I do expect at some point during the movie
somebody will refer to him as the flash there's
a bunch more scenes of him talking to the younger
version of himself from 10 years ago he's meant
to be 10 years younger it's 2013 right before the
events of the Man of Steel movie wins odd attacks
which was released in real life in 2013 so they're
saying the movies have kind of been moving in
real time for the most part that's why there's an
Inception poster and a Pacific Rim poster mostly
because these movies came out relatively recently
and were pretty big right before the Man of Steel
movie The Other obvious connection too is that
Christopher Nolan sort of rebooted Batman so to
speak made Batman cool again with the Dark Knight
trilogy the Christian Bale version of Batman there
might be an Easter egg for him somewhere
in the movie people are expecting cameos
from a bunch of different characters just because
there's so many opportunities when he's traveling
through the speed force and seeing all these other
timelines it's all Canon through the DC Multiverse
the other reason for the Pacific Rim poster of
all different types of posters you could include
here is because Guillermo del Toro has a special
connection with the director Andy muschietti so
when Andy muschetti got his start working on the
film Mama guillerma Del Toro recognized that he
had a lot of potential and became an executive
producer on that movie and they became good
friends it also seems like younger Barry is a
big fan of skateboarding too like there are a
bunch of skateboards some skateboarding posters
there's a longer seat of him explaining to younger
Barry what went wrong with his time traveling
when he was trying to travel through the speed
force messing with timelines mostly this is about
Flashpoint and him getting over the death of his
mother like learning to accept that he can't
change the past even though he has the power
to try just because things go completely off
the rails like that's the whole idea is that
most of them wind up learning the hard way like R
Berry learns the lesson but it's the younger Berry
that doesn't learn the lesson and winds up going
dark turning into dark flash you kind of see that
later in the trailer where you see both berries
yelling at each other like the younger Barry say
no nobody dies and it seems like they're inside
the speed force with the energy all around them
there's a much longer scene to Ben Affleck's
Batman in the present day of the movie it seems
like it's earlier in the movie taking down some
criminals in Gotham City like it's meant to be
just him on a normal day taking down a bunch of
bad guys and it turns into a much bigger action
scene Ben Affleck said during the movie that
there's a Wonder Woman scene during this like
she winds up helping save his life she catches
him with the lasso of Truth and because it's
the lasso of Truth he winds up saying all these
things and revealing all these dark truths about
himself that he wouldn't have otherwise and they
treat it kind of like a funny moment kind of like
the joke that they had with Aquaman in the lasso
of Truth during Justice League and it's my best
I've done I finally figured out how to play the
guy no really I got it for real I was like hold
on am I is that I quit I know I quit and I know I
came back to you but I got it now but it was a it
was a scene where I got I get caught I get saved
by Wonder Woman yeah uh during a a conflagration
with some some some bad guys he saved me with the
lasso of Truth and so what happens is that Batman
um divulges you know some of his
real feelings yeah about about
um his life and his work and uh it helps
you see the character and now you want
another chance to play it and I was like wait
a minute I got it am I still wait can I guys
then there's a scene of Supergirl taking flash
into the clouds and it seems like this is him
trying to get his powers back and she's helping
him by Shocking himself with lightning and she's
taking him up into the clouds so they have a
better chance of him being struck by lightning
like I've said before this seems like a longer
version like a crazier version of the way it
goes down in the flashpoint comics in the Justice
League Flashpoint movie The Trailer footage could
be a little misleading the way that they're
editing it but it seems like the way this goes
down is that he tries to give his younger self
speed force Powers by recreating the accident
where he originally got powers in his lap like
this is a scene right out of the comics with him
being struck by the speed Force lightning and
all the chemicals you notice that the lightning
color is his normal lightning color and it's
striking the younger version of himself but
it arcs through him what might wind up happening
is that he gives his younger self Powers but in
doing so he actually removes his own powers like
he loses his powers then he has to find a way to
give himself Powers again so he tries to keep
shocking himself a bunch of different ways like
look at this crazy device here this is obviously
right out of the comics it seems like when they're
actually creating this part particular device like
he's trying to shock himself inside the bat cave
you actually see the cable connected like the
lightning bolt connected to the bat wing which
is actually hovering in the air that a lot of you
been asking why does the main version of Flash's
color of lightning change it's like reddish gold
now I think this is from after he gets his powers
back the second time the other funny reason why
they have two different colors of lightning is so
that casual viewers who don't know The Flash
comic so they didn't watch The Flash TV show
when they're watching the movie on screen they can
tell the two of them apart when they're fighting
each other or when they're fighting together
there's a much longer scene of them all fighting
Zod and the kryptonians with more footage of
the younger Barry Allen using his powers his
homemade version of The Flash suit using one
of Batman's old bat suits just spray painted
not totally sure why Michael Keaton's Batman
is falling on his knees here probably after
he ejects from the Batwing when the Kryptonian
non smashes his way into the cockpit like he did
during the Man of Steel movie there are a lot of
scenes in the movie that are either parallels or
exact copies of scenes from earlier movies like
The Man of Steel movie in Batman 1989 obviously
I'm sure there'll be a lot more scenes
like that in the movie you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
come on let's get nuts this is a scene of what
it looks like when the flash is traveling through
time into the speed force like other timelines
mostly it looks like he's running in place with
the Multiverse like all these other timelines
hyper time moving around him then there's a
cool scene of the younger Barry Allen shooting
one of the kryptonians with a bolt of speed
Force lightning before he accelerates into him
physically hitting him the thing about the flash
is that the mass of an object increases the
faster it's traveling so when Barry is just
standing around and he hits someone like if he
pushed Batman just standing normally he's not
that strong he's pretty weak it wouldn't have
any effect but when he's traveling at super
speed using the speed force his body gains so
much mass it'd be like someone getting punched
by Superman or someone with crazy strength in a
lot of fandoms characters call that ability an
infinite Mass punch so the flash can do that
during battles like he just accelerates and
punches someone with way higher Mass he'd be like
punching someone with the force of the sun there's
supposed to be a crazy number of cameos because
he is traveling through the speed force he's going
to be seeing a bunch of other timelines I know
people have been wondering is Grant gustin's Flash
from The Flash TV show going to have a cameo
scene and they're going to pay off that crisis
on infinite Earth's Cameo scene I haven't seen
the movie yet but the report right now is that
Grant Gustin is not in the movie and they just
didn't have enough room in the movie to have a
longer scene like they did during crisis on
infinite Earth but there is supposed to be a
CW flash Cameo scene during the movie the real
crazy thing though is that right now the report
is is it is actually Teddy Sears version of Jake
Eric and if you remember if you didn't watch The
Flash TV show he actually played a version of
Hunter zolomon Zoom who was pretending to be
Jay Garrick I don't know how they're going to
explain that like maybe he's just meant to be
a regular version of Jay Garrick From Another
Earth there is supposed to be a cameo from
Nicholas Cage's Superman when flash is traveling
through the speed force it gets real quick blink
and you'll miss it kind of moment but his Superman
is supposed to be fighting a giant robot spider
his movie Superman lives which was going to be
made by Tim Burton they actually started a lot
of pre-production he even had a Superman suit
during the script for that movie they actually
had his character fighting a robot spider like
it was actually going to go down they're making
it seem like those events actually happen like
that movie actually happened just in a different
Universe generally I'm expecting a bunch of
moments like that like real quick blinking
you'll miss it funny references to a bunch of
other really obscure things in the DC history
supposedly there's even going to be a cameo scene
from George Clooney's Batman at the end of the
movie where they pay off the joke about the flash
messing up his time traveling messing up traveling
through the speed force in when he's trying to
go home at the end of the film he accidentally
winds up on George Clooney Batman's Earth meeting
him like oh damn I messed up again if you spotted
any other Easter eggs in this other new trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
them Below in the comments I'm sure there's going
to be a billion questions and we'll start getting
way more trailers for the movie in the next month
there are a bunch of other brand new trailers at
cinemacon so I'll try to do videos for all those
as quickly as possible also lots of report about
Galactus the Fantastic Four movie so there's just
a lot of stuff happening right now don't worry
I will try to do videos for everything everyone
click here for my other big Flash trailer video
in Easter eggs and click here for that brand new
Marvel Craven the hunter trailer video thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe and
I'll see you guys in the next one!